obviously you're back in the suit yeah
suit's the same this time right or there
is it being changed or yes it's the same
yes okay as the last one there's no
changes again i asked for a zip and i
didn't get one
do you have a zip
uh yeah sort of
sort of it's not a conventional zip no
otherwise you'd see it but yeah we're
talking about the same zip right
there
i've said this publicly before because i
really think there should we should do
something about this i actually think
this should like all of us we need to
band together we need to tell somebody
because he he can like you know listen
it's one piece so there's a helmet and
there's all these things that go
underneath it and i always have this
fear that if he's like working really
hard or something's happening that if he
had to like throw up per se
what's how
how is he going to get it out
this is a genuine concern yes right so
it i honestly sometimes when i look at
him i'm like i get a little scared cause
i'm like what if you like i don't know i
don't know i don't know
it just stresses me out
but haven't you you've got better at the
suit though can't you you found a way
can you eat with the suit on some things
some things there's essentially they put
so the eyes pop out and there used to be
these fans i remember them bragging
about they added in these fans that you
could click and it would supposedly cool
me down they worked once
i have these hot batteries
but there's a there's a hole underneath
the eye socket where we used to be able
to feed a tube down oh no and i could
drink without taking the suit off
because it you know it takes a lot of
time and you've got a picture of this if
children have stayed up late to see
spiderman maybe they shouldn't see
spider-man drinking it's it's it's quite
unpleasant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you